CRITICS SAY THE SAUDI REGIME IS
SPORTS WATCHING, ATTEMPTING TO
USE SPORTS TO RESHAPE ITS BRUTAL
IMAGE.
>> BACKED BY SAUDI ARABIA'S
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS, LIV GOLF
COULD FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE THE
PROFESSIONAL MEN'S GAME.
THE NEW SERIES OFFERS PLAYERS
FEWER TOURNAMENTS AND GUARANTEED
PRIZE MONEY, LOTS OF IT.
DUSTIN JOHNSON AND PHIL
MICKELSON ARE THE BIGGEST STARS
TO SIGN UP AND THEY'RE EARNING
MORE FROM THIS THAN THEIR
COMBINED 45 YEARS ON THE TOUR.
>> THIS IS SOMETHING I THOUGHT
WAS BEST FOR ME AND MY FAMILY.
I'M EXCITED ABOUT PLAYING, AND
OBVIOUSLY, THIS IS THE FIRST
WEEK.
YEAH, IT'S SOMETHING EXCITING,
SOMETHING NEW.
AND YEAH, I THINK IT'S GREAT FOR
THE GAME OF GOLF, SO THAT'S WHY
I'M HERE.
>> LIV GOLF CEO GREG NORMAN SAYS
HIS NEW SERIES IS GAME CHANGING,
ESPECIALLY FOR LOWER RANKED
PLAYERS.
>> PGA TOUR DOESN'T GIVE A RAT'S
ASS ABOUT WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
TO YOU AFTER YOU FINISH PLAYING
THE GAME OF GOLF.
THEY DON'T.
>> BUT THE MONEY HASN'T
IMPRESSED EVERYONE.
NORMAN TOLD "THE WASHINGTON
POST" THAT TIGER WOODS TURNED
DOWN A HIGH NINE-FIGURE SUM TO
JOIN.
HE HAS CALLED THE VENTURE
POLARIZING, WHILE JACK NICKLAUS
SAYS HE ALSO REJECTED AN OFFER
TO GET INVOLVED WORTH $100
MILLION.
>> I HAD ZERO INTEREST IN IT.
I DON'T CARE WHAT KIND OF MONEY
THEY HAD THROWN TO ME.
MY ALLEGIANCE HAS BEEN TO THE
PGA TOUR.
I GREW UP WITH THE PGA TOUR, I
HELPED FOUND THE PGA TOUR AS IT
IS TODAY, AND MY ALLEGIANCE IS
THERE.
IT'S GOING TO STAY THERE.
>> IT'S THE BACKING BY SAUDI
ARABIA'S PUBLIC INVESTMENT FUND
CHAIRED BY CROWN PRINCE MOHAMMED
BIN SALMAN THAT HAS ATTRACTED
THE STIFFEST CRITICISM.
THE ARAB NATION HAS LONG BEEN
ACCUSED OF SPORTS WATCHING,
USING SPORTS TO CLEAN UP ITS
REPUTATION FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
ABUSES AND ALLEGED
STATE-SPONSORED KILLINGS.
A U.S. INTELLIGENCE REPORT
CLAIMED BIN SALMAN HIMSELF
SANCTIONED THE MURDER OF
JOURNALIST JAMAL KHASHOGGI IN
2018.
SOMETHING BIN SALMAN DENIES.
EVEN MICKELSON SAID IT WAS SCARY
GETTING INVOLVED WITH THE SAUDIS
BUT HE SAYS GOLF DESPERATELY
NEEDS CHANGE, AND REAL CHANGE IS
ALWAYS PRECEDED BY DISRUPTION.
>> I DON'T CONDONE HUMAN RIGHTS
VIOLATIONS AT ALL.
I DON'T THINK -- NOBODY HERE
DOES.
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD, AND I'M
CERTAINLY AWARE OF WHAT HAS
HAPPENED WITH JAMAL KHASHOGGI
AND I THINK IT'S TERRIBLE.
I HAVE ALSO SEEN THE GOOD THAT
THE GAME OF GOLF HAS DONE
THROUGHOUT HISTORY, AND I
BELIEVE THAT LIV GOLF IS GOING
TO DO A LOT OF GOOD FOR THE GAME
AS WELL.
>> DESPITE THE RESERVATIONS, LIV
GOLF IS FORGING AHEAD WITH EIGHT
TOURNAMENTS THIS YEAR, FIVE OF
WHICH ARE IN THE UNITED STATES
WITH THE SEASON FINALE AT THE
TRUMP NATIONAL DORAL COURSE IN
FLORIDA.
A COUPLE MONTHS AGO, THIS
PROJECT LOOKED FINISHED.
NOW IT HAS A HALL OF FAMER IN
MICKELSON, LAST YEAR'S WORLD
NUMBER ONE IN JOHNSON, AND
REPORTS THAT BRYSON DeCHAMBEAU
WILL BE NEXT.
YOU KNOW, JAKE, MONEY OFTEN
TRUMPS MOR